Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
As you can tell from the gray speckled walls
behind me, I am in an airport, and as you
can tell from my cold dead eyes, it's 5:42
in the morning.
Also, I forgot my camcorder, so I'm filming
this on my phone.
I have a bunch of things to tell you, but
I also wanna give you some travel tips, so
I'm gonna intersperse them.
Thing One Hank, The Paper Towns Movie: they
moved the release date; it is now coming out
on July 24th.
That is the real date; it will really come
out on that day, I think.
That's very good news, because it means that
Jake and everybody will have time to actually
finish the movie.
Also, there is going to be a trailer soon.
How soon?
I can't tell you, but pretty soon.
Ok, travel tip: In almost every airport in
the United States, there is a gate that is
empty all the time.
In our case in Indianapolis, it's gate A3.
This is where I come to make videoblogs, because
there are no people here.
If you're at an airport, take the time to
walk around and find the empty gate, because
there are plugs, and chairs, and freedom.
Sadly that travel tip does not apply to people
in Los Angeles, New York, Chicago, or Atlanta.
Thing Two, The Looking For Alaska movie: So
Hank, my first book, Looking For Alaska, came
out 10 years ago, and the movie rights have
been owned ever since by Paramount.
But suddenly, it seems like a Looking For
Alaska movie might actually happen, because
the team has gotten back together.
The same screenwriters who wrote The Fault
In Our Stars and Paper Towns, Scott Neustadter
and Mike Weber are gonna be writing the script.
And the producers of both Fault In Our Stars
and Paper Towns have joined in as well, so
that is very exciting.
Travel Tip: So, this is the fancy airport
lounge.
Don't pay to go to the airport lounge, it's
never worth it.
You think there's gonna be like milk and honey
and beds in there.
You know what they have?
I'll tell you exactly what's in there.
Alcohol and cookies.
That's it, that's what you will find in the
airport lounge.
So unless you really love to drink, or are
Cookie Monster, there is no way that it's
worth it.
If you want to go to a quiet, private place
in the airport, don't go to the lounge, go
to the chapel.
Almost every airport has a chapel, and they
are always nice, and pleasant, and very quiet
places.
Hank, I noticed most of my travel tips are
like "How do you get away from other travelers?"
Hank, the biggest movie news of all is that
I have seen the Paper Towns movie, and it
is great.
I'm just so psyched about it and so grateful
to everyone who's working on it.
Hank, it's one thing to be faithful to a book's
plot; it's another to be faithful to the themes
of a book.
And I really feel like the Paper Towns movie
is about learning to imagine others complexly,
I'm just so psyched about it.
No spoilers, but I am psyched!
Final travel tip, Hank: When walking on the
moving walkway, be very careful not to step
on a crack, lest you break your mother's back.
Ok Hank, I have to go board.
Sorry about the iPhone video.
July 24th - Paper Towns movie!
I'll see you on Friday!